I know you're fierce I know your
weaknesses I know you better than you
know yourselves sabot are still out
there I'll be ready please tell me
you're seeing him oh I see him
holy crap everybody so much happening in
this flash winter finale footage let's
break it down in heads up the flash ring
giveaway is back for those asking all
you have to do to enter just be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
and make sure you turn alerts on there
is crazy stuff happening this month so
oh my god I cannot believe they're
actually getting this close to mark
hamill Joker on the flash I think what's
going on here is that he just made to
look like the Joker
but he's still playing earth-three
trickster the James Jesse trickster so
Jay Garrick looks like he's been running
afoul of him for a long time now
Barry has to go to earth 3 to get help
with sabot are this is all stuff that's
happening after the crossover so the
official synopsis just reads that the
doctor alchemy savat our team up is just
way too much for Barry to handle so he's
getting super bummed out about Christmas
can't handle like any of the real life
stuff that's going on all he can think
about is sabot AR and dr. alchemy so
even though Wally tries to help out just
like he helped out during the crossover
Barry isn't super happy about that just
because he's worried about Wally getting
hurt like rushing into things too fast
so he goes to earth 3 gets help from Jay
Garrick it looks like he helps Jay
Garrick with his trickster problem then
they both come back in Jay Garrick helps
out with sabot R but you see him like
falling off the building here so they
really want you to think that something
really bad is gonna happen to Jay
Garrick but TV likes to play a lot of
tricks on you like think about what just
happened to Wally he came in had a
really awesome take down in this last
episode of the flash but then Supergirl
put him on his ass so he was out of
commission for a little while but even
if something terrible happens to Jay
Garrick just think about the Ronnie
Raymond firestorm multiverse workaround
so Robbie Amell gets questions all the
time about if he's ever coming back to
the flash are you ever gonna play the
Ronnie Raymond firestorm again and he's
like well there's a multiverse out there
Supergirl is confirmed on earth 38
that's 36 other versions that could be
out there because earth to Ronnie
Raymond death storm may he rest in peace
also died during flash season 2 but
let's talk about trickster stuff Ferg
so mark hamill coming for the mid-season
finale is now a three time tradition so
that makes me wonder what they're gonna
try and do with him next year it's just
that there's like a break in his Star
Wars filming schedule that allows him to
do this so I'm so happy about it because
usually he has to shave yes to grow the
beard out for Luke
so it's always a question of what his
availability is gonna be because next
year there'll be episode 9 filming going
on so hopefully he's done in time to
come back for another episode of the
flash next year having him around is
such a big deal one because he's a
really big actor too because he's an
amazing actor in three because he's a
really big character with a long history
of Jay Garrick john wesley shipp Barry
Allen stuff so john wesley shipp has
talked a lot about his version of jay
garrick on the flash he's calling him
like his version of Barry from that
original 90s flash series just 20-plus
years into the future so pretend that
the world of Earth 3 is the world of
that 90s flash series the big difference
with the comics multiverse and the TV
show multiverse is that earth 3 in the
comics is crime syndicate earth and they
kind of did that with earth 2 with his
big evil meta tema the zoom hat in
season 2 it's kind of funny but you see
like the bomb strapped to his chest you
see a theme start to appear the first
episode he had where he teamed up with
his son the second version of the
trickster he had a bomb strapped to his
chest he was gonna blow a bunch of
people up the second time he came back
in season 2 he was also trying to blow
up half of the city with a bunch of
bombs in presence so it'll be fun to see
what he tries to blow up this year but I
love Mark Hamill he's one of the best
character actors most people just think
about Luke Skywalker Star Wars stuff but
he's done so much animated voice-over
work
the Joker is just the biggest character
that everybody remembers thinking how do
I laugh I'm on the freeways in LA in Los
Angeles but let me know in the comments
what is your favorite Mark Hamill
character that is not Luke Skywalker
I felt like we can all say that the
Joker is probably our favorite Mark
Hamill character everybody loves Luke
Skywalker but his Joker is so timeless
and what about all this avatar dr.
alchemy stuff that's going on in the
episode most of you probably noticed
that dr. alchemy is speaking with a
different voice in this trailer than he
was in the first couple of episodes that
he appeared in this season that is now
because I think that that original voice
when we first heard him speak was
speaking with savatage voice the
voiceover you hear in this trailer is
all dr. alchemy there's no sabotage
speaking I mean he appears in the
trailer but he doesn't speak he talks
about knowing all their secrets all
their weaknesses it shows you iris West
so you start to put two and two together
and you're like oh but if something
happens to iris West because during the
crossover episode we saw a future
newspaper that was not written by iris
West so a lot of you guys were like wait
a minute does that mean that she dies in
the current version of events so they're
gonna try and change that this season
Candice Patton is always gonna be a big
character on the flash like they're not
gonna kill off iris West for good the
flash is one of those TV shows though
where they can have moments like that
where they kill someone and then bring
it right back just because of all the
ways that people's powers work and
there's a lot this season that they're
doing with the Flash's powers that we
haven't seen before the way they
characterize the Speed Force
thus avatar character who is a little
Full Metal Alchemist
if you guys haven't seen that series
Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood has a
character that's essentially like a soul
bonded to a suit of armor so even though
there's a person in that suit of armor
there's no physical body like his
consciousness is in there so that might
be what's happening with Savitt are it's
also kind of a super deep cut but during
the Stargate TV series there was a
character called Anubis that was like a
half ascended being that existed in this
in-between sort of transdimensional
state where he could kind of assume a
semi corporeal form
but the beings like the higher beings
that existed in that universe could not
act against him they're kind of like the
all-powerful gods like the Speed Force
wormhole aliens that we saw during the
flash season two that Barry met inside
the Speed Force but because he existed
in this in-between state between pure
God and pure normal person like Barry
almost no one could act against him so
that might be why Savitt R is so much
more of a threat than zoom because zoom
was really powerful he was faster than
Barry but when he messed with time too
much the Speed Force
itself acted against him sent the time
rates and turned him into the black
flash carrying him off but then if
Savitt are so bad how come that doesn't
happen to him
it just feels like the show has been
telling us that he exists in this
in-between state like we see him running
through pure Speed Force not
three-dimensional space so I know it
sounds a little confusing but just
imagine someone traveling as pure energy
that's kind of what it would look like
to the human eye
like he appears in a bolt of lightning
when he's fighting Barry but it sounds
like he's stuck in that state like he
can't completely manifest a physical
body in the real world and that's what
he's trying to do with the help of dr.
alchemy I know a lot of you are
wondering if this is a version of future
Barry like the blue flash from the
comics I don't think the show is that
pessimistic I don't think it would go
down that route but ultimately they want
you that writers want you to believe in
Barry so I'd be blown away if they ever
actually turn Barry into a villain of
the series Barry's always gonna do
really stupid stuff but ultimately the
idea is that he's the hero of the series
so they don't ever want to poison the
audience against Barry like they don't
want you to root against Barry but I can
only imagine how the iris west superfans
are going to riot whence avatar
ultimately takes a swipe at her even
though the show would never a kill her
off but that doesn't mean that she's
immune from evil speedsters in alchemy
says in the trailer I know all your
weaknesses
speaking of which dr. alchemy we pretty
much know what's going on with his
character so what is up with the
Julianne character it sounds like
they're going with a split personality
situation because Julianne himself seems
like he doesn't hate Barry but this
alchemy persona seems like he's trying
to bring about this grand apocalypse so
thats avatar can come back but you do
wonder if it's like a firestorm
situation like how's the TV show going
to address this multiple personality is
it like firestorm whereby like when dr.
alchemy is doing stuff the julian
consciousness is still aware of what's
going on even though he's not fully in
control and that's probably something
we're just gonna have to wait to find
out because tom
Olsen is gonna be a big character for
the entire season so they're probably
gonna take their time explaining what
the hell is going on with dr. alchemy
even though we kind of know what the
identity twist is we just don't know the
reason behind it yet but you guys can
let me know like what is your theory
behind dr. alchemy and Julie and Albert
is he really an evil person or is it a
split personality and what do you think
is gonna happen to Jay Garrick do you
think this avatar will just almost kill
him put him out of commission so that
quote-unquote he has to go away for a
couple episodes before he can come back
like they use him very sparingly like
this very little Jay Garrick this season
so far and a lot of you have been asking
me about Jay Garrick on legends of
tomorrow I ultimately think he'll
eventually go there I haven't seen any
confirmation from the producers or the
actors that they're actually gonna do
that but John Wesley Shipp himself said
that he felt like they were probably
going to do that he just kind of did
that thing that we all do where it's
like well Jay Garrick is a huge Justice
Society character they're doing Justice
Society on the TV shows now it makes
sense that they would try to find a
place for him but I'll talk a little bit
more about that when I post my legends
video this week that's Thursday it'll be
the fourth night of the crossover you
guys can let me know if you've been
finding my crossover videos just fine I
put different titles on the thumbnails
just to distinguish them from normal
episodes like part 1 part 2 part 3 and
then part 4 so there's only four parts
to the crossover so I just put those on
there so you would know which order the
episodes are happening in in which order
to watch the videos in you don't have to
watch them in order but I just put those
on there in case people have no idea
what's going on but what's gonna happen
next is I'm gonna do a Rick and Morty
season 3 trailer video if you have no
idea what that show is I'll try to
explain there'll be a couple more bonus
videos but that's getting ready to get
started so I'll explain in that video
there was also new agents of shield
there was a different Ghost Rider that
appeared big twist so that video might
not post till Thursday but I will do an
agents of shield Ghost Rider video it's
just that because of all the DC
craziness this week a lot of other stuff
that isn't an emergency is second
priority so don't worry agents of shield
coming Rick and Morty coming next
then arrow 100th episode so get hype
while you guys wait for that to post you
can click here for my crossover part 2
video and you can click here for the
part 1 video thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight